headphones that clean your ears you
stick this thing in your ear and you
like water and then you can see the
nastiness coming out of your ears this
is the weirdest ever imagine you
want a Subway you on a bus somebody come
in they got headphones like this and I'm
just you know I'm like oh I don't even
know if they really do music but I just
when they say headphones I think it's
music right so you just you know you
boom and then somebody you know and then
like somebody's sitting next to you and
they see like
you know there's a wax and water
building up inside the thing right there
and you all like that yo what up what's
up you like huh what's up
I'll just that's my I'm cleaning my ears
you know but you know I'm also rocking
that Drake right now you know what I
mean so it's like oh dude yuck this
would be like wearing clear pants that
they all the pants also work as a diaper
and a toilet you just walking around and
Boo-Boo is just sloshing around your
legs you know what I mean and you got
your cleaning headphones on you like yo
what up yeah I'm just what's up yeah I
just pooped that's what that is had to
take a big one right ain't that
something yeah I'm cleaning my ears
right now too
[Music]